What we're thinking about things we're
already seeing.
Um,
uh,
warm air holds more water vapor than
cold.
Um,
the atmosphere is about 5% more moisture
in it then it had 40 years ago,
which is an astonishingly large change
in a basic physical parameter.
Uh,
that means that we're seeing huge
increases in the amount of day and
downpour and flood.
There's a record rainfall and flood
event someplace around the world almost
every week.
Now,
the hundred year storm comes to many
places every three or four years.
Uh,
it's taking a great toll on
infrastructure,
on human life.
You know,
if this spring we watched,
uh,
hundreds of people killed in Rio,
in the middle of Rio de Janeiro in mud
slides after the largest rainstorms
they'd ever recorded in that city.
Um,
uh,
look at the chemistry of seawater.
I mean,
the ocean is the,
our metaphor for vastness on this
planet,
but that hasn't stopped it from changing
in profound ways.
See waters 30% more acidic and it was 40
or 50 years ago because the oceans are
absorbing so much carbon from the
atmosphere.
Everything frozen on earth is melting.
Glaciers are melting with great
rapidity,
uh,
all over the planet.
Some of them have disappeared in the
western us,
in the Andes.
Um,
um,
you can go on for many days just listing
the effects we've already seen.
If we don't do things quickly,
the effects that are coming as the
temperature gets hotter and hotter will
be even more dramatic.
Uh,
the latest studies indicate that by the
mid to latter part of the century,
we could be seeing grain yields for corn
and soybean and wheat fall 20,
30,
40%.
Um,
that would be trouble of a,
uh,
a all encompassing sword,
new planet.
We need new habits,
new ways of going about things.
The biggest habit on our planet at the
moment is a kind of,
uh,
addiction to economic growth and to the
idea that growth will solve every
problem that we face.
Um,
that's a habit we're going to have to
habit of mind really,
that we're going to have to get out of.
Uh,
we've reached those limits to growth
that people started talking about it in
the 1970s when you melt the Arctic,
that's a pretty good sign that you've
gone too far.
And so we're going to need to figure out
instead how to build a world that is
stable,
secure,
kinda hunker down that's built for,
uh,
built for endurance,
not for speed,
a con.
I think that means more and more than
our economies will need to become more
localized,
less sprawling,
uh,
less vulnerable,
more resilient.
We can see that starting slowly to
happen.
The number of farms in the United States
increased last five years for the first
time in a century and a half.
And it's because there's this local food
movement that's building up that kind of
resilience in place after place.